hi YouTube our defense
I'm jelly I mean Davos this first time
for me come here and need a lot of new
friends I just have the medium which I'm
very proud of like a map Roger in the
bill kids and why I come here
and I'm making movies and so I started
foundation cut of one because why waste
one people like owners have given
culture different religion different
languages but we're human
that's the first one secondly we'll have
to send body about a family you know
everybody work very hard
why take care family mother sister
brother and no and younger brothers so I
think that's the water human instead
when we talk about the philanthropy
everybody talk about a watch it had
money money money if you will not have a
lot of money we can solve a lot of
problems
I think money is a great things you know
we're happen I'm at the other hand
person and only in the visa is still
also very important
my belief is if you where to leave this
global family this urge is our home
everybody to little bit to be here is
home hey rich people they need a do
their job government knew they needed do
their job
we're just normal human being we could
do little bit like a volunteer one hour
per month donate when you get movin
dollar per month
put on the pool take care this home make
sure this home you know fresh healthy
you know maybe if it's these years later
take this home next generation
yes I called is the 21st century
philosophy culture it's my belief
everybody do together all the family
know where the one which hands together
I hope you find me when foundation run
family thank you